Joe Biden is funding a genocide.
Oh come on. You know Trump will be worse, right?
Come on. You know the Trump bad rhetoric isn't working anymore.
What's your fine?
Throwing the election even with abortion and LGBTQ rights on the line?
No. Yes.
The Democrats are just the pride flag side of the same coin.
What have they actually done?
How about what they haven't done?
Like try to overthrow an election?
Ban abortion? I mean jeez,
have you guys heard about Project Lane 25?
Here comes the fear monger.
Guys, do you not see this is exactly what the right wants
and how we lost in 2016?
Okay, you're gonna blame Hillary's loss on us again?
No, actually I blame the dums.
What?
All the Democrats have done since 2016 is run unpopular candidates
whose only platform is Trump bad
and sure, while they hold the line.
It's a line drawn by Republicans.
It may be a welcome pause from all the bullshit,
but it's still nothing more than a pause.
Wow, so you're cool Trump winning again?
You're supporting fascism?
No, when saying is a system where we're always voting against something
and not for anything
isn't sustainable.
You doubling down on the Trump bad
rhetoric isn't gonna win over anyone.
But you can't keep blaming a genocide on win an election year
when we know Trump will do worse in the Middle East.
You're just dividing the left.
The left is already divided.
You can't just pretend It's not happening.
And ignoring people's valid criticisms of the Democrats
is only furthering that divide.
I don't care who listens to me.
I'm not voting for a genocidal capitalist
just so Democrats can do nothing for the next four years.
Election arguably isn't about the next four years.
It's about what comes after.
What do you mean?
If Republicans win again,
we know what they'll do.
They'll further dismantle human rights
that everyday Americans depend on.
Which means in 2028,
all the Democrats have to do is say, we're not the other guy again.
And then we get more of this hold the line BS,
and that line will be even further right.
But was that even matter?
If Democrats will still
do nothing more than hold the line for the next four years,
it means they won't have a scapegoat. In 2028,
the state of the union will be entirely on them.
Which means they'll have to start addressing the concerns on the left
if they wanna have a successful platform.
That's why Sanders was so popular.
After eight years of Obama,
Sanders lost against a democratic establishment that was gun ho
and running on nothing more than Trump bad.
Yet since 2016,
we've seen more and more progressives running for office.
And the reason they're so popular
is because they're actually for something
rather than just against someone.
We're not gonna come together and agree on everything.
We can spend the next four years organizing
on the Ground for something better.
That doesn't happen
if we're defending basic human rights from Republicans
so Democrats can run on other guy bad messaging again and again.
We'll just be stuck in this loop forever.